GOING TO CALL THIS MEETING TO
ORDER SO THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE HAS
BEEN CALLED THE ORDER REMINDER
TO EVERYONE. TODAY'S HEARING
CONSISTS OF ITEMS THAT ARE ON
SUSPENSE. ALL OF THE MEASURES
HAVE ALREADY HAD A HEARING. ONE
OF MY PET PEEVES IS, PEOPLE WILL
SAY WHEN WE DISPENSE WITH THE
SUSPENSE FILE. HOW COME WE
DIDN'T HAVE A HEARING? HOW COME
EVERY SINGLE ONE OF THESE BILLS
HAS HAD A HEARING. EVERY SINGLE
ONE OF THESE BILLS HAS HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR BOTH PROPONENTS
AND OPPONENTS TO SPEAK FOR OR
AGAINST EVERY SINGLE ONE OF THE
BILL. SO PLEASE STOP
MISCALCULATE CHARACTERIZING.
WHAT HAPPENS ON SUSPENSE IS A
LACK OF HEARING BECAUSE THE
HEARINGS ALREADY HAPPENED, UM AS
NOTED IN THE DAILY FILE. IT'S A
VOTE ONLY, UH, BEFORE WE BEGIN,
UH MAKE A FEW COMMENTS. UM WE
WILL BE MOVING QUICKLY THROUGH
THE AGENDA ALPHABETICALLY BY
AUTHOR'S NAME PLAY COAST
ATTENTION BECAUSE WE WILL ONLY
BE ADDRESSING THE MEASURES THAT
WILL BE UP FOR A VOTE IF YOU
DON'T HEAR BILL TAKEN UP. THAT
MEANS THE BILL IS UNDER IS HELD
UNDER SUBMISSION AUTOMATICALLY
ANNOUNCED AUTHOR MEASURE NUMBER
AND PROVIDE A BRIEF DESCRIPTION
OF ANY AMENDMENTS TO THE MEASURE
BEFORE WE TAKE THE VOTE. UM AND
OBVIOUSLY FOLLOWING THE HEARING,
ALL THE RESULTS AND ACTIONS WILL
BE ON THE SENATE COMMITTEE. AND
I BELIEVE EVEN REVISED ANALYSIS
WILL BE PUT UP OF ANY BILLS THAT
ARE AMENDED. IF IT AFFECTS THE
FISCAL, THERE'LL BE A REVISED
ANALYSIS. UM WE'LL ALSO AGAIN
HOSTING THE ADDENDUM ANALYSIS.
SO LET'S ESTABLISH OUR QUORUM.
MADAM SECRETARY. PORTANTINO I'M
HERE. YOU KNOW HERE, JONES JONES
HERE. ASHBY BRADFORD BRADFORD
HERE. SARTO TOHIR HOB. WIENER.
WE HAVE A CHOIR. UM AND WE NEED
WE'RE MISSING TWO MEMBERS. SO I
SERGEANTS IF WE COULD, PLEASE,
BECAUSE IT'S MUCH EASIER TO DO
THIS. WE'RE GOING TO TAKE A ROLL
CALL ON EVERY VOTE BECAUSE WE
ONLY HAVE A SHORT AGENDA. AND SO
I'LL WAIT ANOTHER 30 SECONDS FOR
THE OTHER TWO MEMBERS IF THEY
COME.
WHO WANTS AN EASY QUESTION.
ERIN, YOU WANT AN EASY QUESTION?
WHAT FAMOUS US FESTIVAL HOSTED
350,000 PEOPLE IN 1969
WOODSTOCK. I TOLD YOU IT WAS
EASY. ISN'T THERE ANOTHER ONE
THAT WAS ACTUALLY BIGGER. I'M
SURE THERE HAVE BEEN FESTIVALS
THAT SAME YEAR, HUH? SUMMER, SO.
BLACK. WELL, YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT GLORIA JONES. DR JONES. DR
JONES. WHEN WALT DISNEY WAS A
CHILD, WHICH CHARACTER DID HE
PLAY IN HIS HIGH SCHOOL PLAY?
PETER PAN. PETER PAN. VERY GOOD.
BRADFORD WHAT SPORT IS DUBBED
THE KING OF SPORTS. IT'S SPORTS.
WORSE IS THEY CALL THAT THE
SPORT OF KINGS, BUT THE KING OF
SPORTS IS SOCCER. BELIEVE IT OR
NOT BAD INFORMATION DIFFERENT. I
DON'T LIKE YOU, RIGHT? SEYARTO
WHAT IS THE PROFESSIONAL ICE
HOCKEY TEAM BASED IN TORONTO,
CALLED TRYING TO MAKE THEM
TORONTO MAPLE LEAFS GOOD JOB.
WIENER WHO WAS THE FIRST GYMNAST
TO SCORE A PERFECT 10 IN THE
OLYMPICS? GOODNESS, A MARY LOU
RETTON'S, BUT NO, NADIA COMING
EACH MY BAD. PUT THAT IN YOUR
MIND. ALL RIGHT. WE NEED ONE
MORE.
WHO WAS THE FIRST WOMAN DRIVER
TO SCORE POINTS AND A GRAND
PRIX. 1975 SPANISH GRAND PRIX
WHO WAS THE DRIVER? WASN'T IT?
WHAT'S YOUR NAME? HOUSTON STOCK
CARS. WHO KNOWS PATRICK BEFORE
DONICA WAS LOMBARDI WOULDN'T
NEVER GOT. YEAH I DON'T KNOW.
AND THEN OUR FINAL TRIVIA
QUESTION BECAUSE ONCE WE START
WE'RE GOING TO GO THROUGH IS HOW
MANY POINTS DID MICHAEL JORDAN'S
SCORE IN HIS FIRST NBA GAME? 16.
WELL THOSE ARE OUR TRIVIA
QUESTIONS FOR THE DAY. WE'RE
GOING TO START ALL RIGHT. AND
THEN WE'RE GONNA UNFORTUNATELY
HAVE TO GO BACK. WE'RE GOING TO
START WITH SENATOR ALLEN SP
575571. ON FIRE SAFETY
REGULATIONS FOR DEVELOPMENT
PROJECTS. IT IS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION. MADAM SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. PORTANTINO
PORTANTINO I. JONES. ASHBY
BRADFORD BRADFORD. I SEE ARTO
ARTO HOB. WIENER WIENER? AYE. MY
VOTE IS FOR ZEELAND BILL IS OUT
FOR 20 WILL HOLD THE ROLL OPEN.
UH IF YOU HOLD THE ROLL OPEN,
AND THEN WE'LL LET IT OUT. SB
820 ALVARADO GIL CANNABIS
SEIZURE OF PROPERTY. IT'S A DO
PASS. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
PORTANTINO I KNOW I JONES JONES
I ASHBY BRADFORD BRADFORD. I
SEE. ARTO ARTO, IOWA HOB. WIENER
WIENER. I 5 TO 0 THAT HAS A 5 TO
0 VOTE WILL HOLD THE ROLL OPEN.
WE'LL MOVE ON. SB 719 BECKER LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES. RADIO
COMMUNICATION IS A DUE PASSI AS
AMENDED PER AUTHOR TO EXEMPT
PUBLIC HIGHER EDUCATION, POLICE
DEPARTMENTS AND REQUIRE
IMPLEMENTATION BY JANUARY, 1
2025 AND COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS TO
CLARIFY THE TYPES OF TACTICAL
OPERATIONS THAT ARE SUBJECT TO
THE PUBLIC ACCESS EXEMPTION. I
WILL CALL THE ROLL PORTANTINO
PORTANTINO I. JONES JOHN'S NO
ASHBY. BRADFORD BRADFORD. I SEE
ARTO ARTO NO ONE HOB WIENER
WIENER. AYE. ORDERS 3 TO 2 WILL
IS ON CALL 3 TO 2. SB SEVEN.
BLAKE SPEAR HOUSING FOR
EXTREMELY LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLDS
TO DO PASS AS AMENDED PER AUTHOR
TO DELETE CURRENT REQUIREMENTS
AND INSTEAD REQUIRE LOCAL ANNUAL
PROGRESS REPORTS TO INCLUDE DATA
ON THE PRODUCTION OF EXTREMELY
LOW INCOME HOUSING. POLICE CALL
THE ROLL. PORTANTINO PORTANTINO,
AYE, JONES ASHBY. BRADFORD
BRADFORD. I SEE ARTO. HOB WINNER
WIENER. AYE, VOTERS. 3 TO 0.
THAT BILL IS ON CALL 3 TO 0 SP
37 CAVALLERO OLDER ADULTS ADULTS
WITH DISABILITIES HOUSING
STABILITY PROGRAM. IT IS A Dð
PASSES AMENDED PER AUTHOR TO
LIMIT THE NEW PROGRAM TO FIVE
REGION PILOT AND SIMPLIFY
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS. PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL IMPORTANT, YOU
KNOW, PORTANTINO I JONES ASHBY.
BRADFORD BRADFORD. I SEE ARTO
WIENER WIENER I ZERO. CALL 3 TO
0. SB 768 CAVALLERO VM T USE IN
SEQUA. IT IS A DO PASS. PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. PORTANTINO
PORTANTINO I. JONES JONES? NO,
ASHBY. BRADFORD. BRADFORD I SEE
ARTO ARTO NO. ONE HOB HOB I
WIENER WIENER I FINAL BIRTHDAY
PARTY TO THAT BILL IS OUT FOR
TWO TO WE'RE GOING TO GO BACK TO
SP 571 ALLEN, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBER. THE MOTION IS
PASSED TO THE SENATE FLOOR CHAIR
VOTING AYE. WAHAB. SB 57 MONTHS.
WE'LL HAVE BY. THAT BILL IS OUT
TO 05 TO ZERO. SB 820. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. THE
MOTION IS PASSED TO THE SENATE
FLOOR. UM HOW MUCH IS THIS
LUNCH? UH HUH. 820 AS WE HAD 20
ASHBY HOB HAVE I? THAT WAS OUT 6
TO 0. SB 719 BECKER. MOTION IS
DUE PASS AMENDED TO THE SENATE
FLOOR. ASHBY. HOB. I. 42 IS OUT
FOR TWO TO SB SEVEN. BLAKE
SPEAR. MOTION IS DUE PASS AMEND
TO THE SENATE FLOOR. JONES,
ASHBY. CIERTO. HOB. WHICH ONE IS
THIS? THE SEVEN SB SEVEN. THE
BOY SHE GIVES ME THEY ONLY HAVE
THREE AND I APPRECIATE IT. WELL,
HAVE I. 4 TO 0 WAS OUT FOR 20
ALRIGHT SP 37 CAVALLERO. THE
MOTION IS DUE PASS THEM INTO THE
SENATE FLOOR. JONES ASHBY.
CIERTO. HOB. PAPA I ZERO IS OUT
FOR 20. OKAY WE'VE CAUGHT UP.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO CORTEZ
ES BEFORE 83 STUDENT PHONE
RESTRAINT. ACTION BE PRONE
RESTRAINT. IT IS A DO PASS.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. PORTANTINO
PORTANTINO I. JONES ASHBY.
BRADFORD BRADFORD. I SEE ARTO
ARTO, IOWA HOB BY WIENER WIENER
I ZERO FELLAS OUT 6 TO 0. SB 733
GLASER SOLITARY CONFINEMENT.
IT'S A DO PASS. PORTANTINO
PORTANTINO I. JONES JONES, ASHBY
. BRADFORD BRADFORD. I SEE ARTO
HIWA HOB HOB I WIENER WIENER I
ZERO BILL IS OUT 6 TO 0 MOVING
ON SB 875 GLASER RESIDENTIAL
CARE FACILITIES FOR THE ELDERLY.
IT'S A DO PASS. PORTANTINO
PORTANTINO I, JONES JONES. I
ASHBY BRADFORD BRADFORD. I SEE
ARTO ARTO, IOWA HOB I WIENER
WIENER. AYE. 50 0 IS OUT 6 TO 0
MOVING ONTO LIMÓN 782
GUBERNATORIAL APPOINTMENTS
REPORT. IT IS A DO PASS. PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. PORTANTINO
PORTANTINO I. JONES JONES II
ASHBY. BRADFORD BRADFORD. I SEE
ARTO ARTO IOWA. HOB HAVE I
WINNER WINNER? AYE. BILL IS OUT
6 TO 0. SB 764 PADILLA MINORS
ONLINE PLATFORM AND DO PASS.
PORTANTINO AYE, NÓI JONES. SB
764 PADILLA. JONES. I ASHBY.
BRADFORD BRADFORD. I SEE ARTO.
WUHAN. HAVE I WIENER WIENER? I
ZERO IS OUT 5 TO 0 MOVING ON THE
SP 53 PORTANTINO FIREARM
STORAGES TO DO PASS. PORTANTINO
NÓI. JONES JONES. NO, ASHBY
BRADFORD BRADFORD I CIERTO
CIERTO NOBLE HUB BY WIENER
WIENER. AYE. 42 FELLAS OUT FOR
TWO TO SB 480 PORTANTINO KOREAN
MEISTER HIGH SCHOOL SYSTEM TO DO
PASS PORTANTINO PORTANTINO I,
JONES JONES. I ASHBY BRADFORD
BRADFORD. I SEE ARTO ARTO, IOWA.
HOB HOB BY WIENER WIENER I ZERO
IS OUT 6 TO 0. SB 691 PORTANTINO
STATE BOARD OF EDUCATION STUDENT
MEMBERS DO PASS PORTANTINO NÓI.
JONES JONES. NO, ASHBY. BRADFORD
BRADFORD. I SEE ARTO ARTO NÓ
WUHAN. BY WIENER WIENER. AYE. IS
OUT FOR TWO TO MOVING ON TO SP
230 SEYARTO ON INCOME TAX HEALTH
SAVINGS ACCOUNTS. PORTANTINO
IMPORTANT. NÓI JONES JONES. I
ASHBY BRADFORD. BRADFORD. I SEE
ARTO. I KNOW I WILL HOB BY
WIENER WIENER NÓ. 5 TO 1 WAS OUT
5 TO 1. MOVING ON TO SKINNER. SB
59 MENSTRUAL PRODUCT
ACCESSIBILITY ACTED AS A Dð
PASSES AMENDED PER AUTHOR, TOO
NARROW SCOPE ONLY TO STATE OWNED
AND USED AND USED BUILDINGS.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. PORTANTINO
PORTANTINO I JONES. ASHBY
BRADFORD BRADFORD. I SEE ARTO.
HOB WIENER WIENER? AYE. 4 TO 0
IS OUT FOR 20 MOVING ON THE 254.
SKINNER CORRECTIONAL FACILITIES.
MEDIA ACCESS. IT'S A DUE PASSI
AS AMENDED PER AUTHOR TO REMOVE
CITY AND COUNTY JAILS. CALL THE
ROLL PORTANTINO IMPORTANT TO NÓI
. JONES JONES. NO ASHBY
BRADFORD. BRADFORD I SEE ARTO
SEYARTO NOVA HOB HOB BY WIENER.
WIENER I 42 PILLARS OUT FOR TWO
TO HAMBURG MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONS. IT'S A DO PASS.
IT'S SB 26 PORTANTINO. AYE NÓI.
JONES JONES. I ASHBY BRADFORD.
BRADFORD I SEE ARTO ARTO, IOWA.
HOB HOB BY WIENER WIENER. I 06
TO ZERO SP MOVING ON THE WAHABI
SP 575 UNDERAGE MARRIAGES DO
PASS. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
PORTANTINO PORTANTINO I JONES
ASHBY. BRADFORD. BRADFORD I SEE
ARTO ARTO, IOWA HOB I WIENER
WIENER. AYE. 20 IS OUT 5 TO 0
MOVING ON TO OUR FINAL AUTHOR SP
85 WIENER REFUGEES SOCIAL
SERVICES THAT DO PASS PORTANTINO
IMPORTANT TO NÓI JONES. NO.
JONES NO ASHBY, BRADFORD.
BRADFORD I SEE ARTO ARTO, NOVA
HAM WINNER WINNER I WAS OUT FOR
TWO. SB 294 WIENER INDEPENDENT
MEDICAL REVIEW. IT'S A DO PASS
THE ROLE PORTANTINO HIÂU NÓI
JONES. OH, ASHBY. BRADFORD
BRADFORD. I SEE ARTO ARTO NOVA
HOB WILL HAVE I WIENER WIENER?
AYE. I WANTED YOU. THAT BILL IS
OUT FOR TWO TO OUR FINAL BILL IS
SP 312 WIENER SEIKO EXEMPTION
UNIVERSITY HOUSING. IT'S A DO
PASS. PORTANTINO AYE NÓI JONES.
HI JONES. I ASHBY BRADFORD
BRADFORD. I CIERTO CIERTO, IOWA.
HA HAVE I WIENER WIENER? I 60 0
OUT 6 TO 0. THAT IS THE EXTENT
OF OUR BILLS TODAY AS MENTIONED,
ALL THE ACTIONS WILL BE ON OUR
WEBSITE LATER TODAY AND AMENDED
ANALYSIS WILL BE REFLECTED AND,
UM WE WILL BE BACK IN BUSINESS
WITH A NEW SLATE OF BILL SHORTLY
AND MORE TRIVIA. QUESTIONS IN
THE NEAR FUTURE. WITH THAT,
EVERYBODY. THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE. THANK YOU. STAFF AND THIS
MEETING IS ADJOURNED.